nevada is still struggling to get the
chronovirus vaccine to the public
now local health officials are getting
more help from the federal government
a pop-up vaccination site opens up this
morning and hector mckeon is live from
doolittle senior center with more on
that good morning to you hector hey
there alex good morning and these pop-up
sites are dedicated to populations that
have been disproportionately affected
by the virus doolittle senior center
here opens at eight o'clock this morning
for those who are 70 and up
however there are no more appointments
available and so far nevada has
distributed around 250
000 doses of the covet 19 vaccine
we're still near the bottom when it
comes to our vaccination rate
but we have improved to 46th nationally
according to a daily tracker from
bloomberg news
starting today the through friday
doolittle senior center will distribute
the first doses of the kobe 19 vaccine
to those 70 and older people registered
ahead of time through the city of las
vegas
and the city says those appointments
were filled up quickly
this is not the only pop-up clinic
though another one opened in sun city
summerlin for seniors this week but
those appointments
are also full and people have been
scrambling to get an appointment select
smith's and walgreens locations are also
offering
the vaccine to seniors and you can make
an appointment through the health
district's website but
this morning it says are no more
available there and to keep checking
again
reporting live this morning hector mejia
8 news now yeah we keep hearing that
from a lot of viewers all right hector
thanks so much for that
the vaccine site at the convention
center opened up yesterday this one's
only for people who need their second
dose
and got the first dose at a site run by
the health district
nevada is still receiving a limited
number of doses as hector was just
talking about
and there are concerns about people
getting their second shot on time
and that is why federal support staff
are in town to help speed things up
we have more information about the
process and how to get an appointment
how to ali set up for one on
eightnewsnow.com